ми дооснащуємо ці мішки Ми повинні бути
згуртованими в постійному режимі Будемо
допомагати щоденно з тої ми обов'язково
переможемо славу
Україні вирішили допомогти армії кинули
Клич в соціальних мережа люди вілкнулися
допомогли створити укріплення для наших
військових у вигляді мішків з пісками
кнулося дуже-дуже багато людей ми
продемонстрували нашу єдність ми
обов'язково переможемо у цій війні яку
розв'язала проти нас Російська Федерація
Слава Україні ми робимо дуже велику
справу будемо здавати треба ми не знаємо
яка ситуація буде якщо ви хочете
допомогти робіть це
правильно Кожен повинен робити свою
роботу підтримувати збройні сили України
сьогодні є заклики здавати кров сьогодні
є заклики перераховувати кошти і різну
допомогу нашим збройним силам сьогодні
прийшло понад 500 людей добродіїв щоб
здати
кров чернівчани об'єдналися тут ми
готуємось допомагаємо посільне Більо
каремати фасуємо і відправляємо перемога
Буде за нами звертаюся ще раз з
проханням хто має можливість допомогти
матрасам каріматами спальними мішками
розкладушками поселити в себе вдома
спільними зусиллями ми поборемо цього
клятого ворога і перемога Буде за нами
Україна
[музика]
вистоєть
спілкувалися з 44ю нашою бригадою
дізналися що є потреби в певних
продуктах харчування і ми зібрали
оперативно те що с швидко змогли
доставили сюди надіємося що в постійному
режимі Будемо допомагати як 44тй бригаді
так і всім збройним силам України до
перемоги Слава Україні закликаю вссіх
тернополян офіс єропеської солідарност
знаходиться за адресою вли нка 11 можна
нести речі які допомагають наблизити
нашу перемогу кожен із вас Зробіть будь
ласка маленький крок в сторону нашої
великої майбутньої Перемоги Я сьогодні
зробила ось це може хтось може зварити
курку і зробити бульйон для дитини може
хтось може зробити голубці Може хтось
може напекти пиріжків Давайте зробимо
кожен із вас щось Що принесе ско нам
допомогу перемога Буде за нами Україна
вистоїть Слава
Україні